si le président mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues madame
la ministre alors que l'encadrement par
la loi riste de la rémunération de
l'intérim médical dans le secteur public
va entrer en application à partir du 3
avril une vive inquiétude monte de un
peu partout en France des ruptures
d'activité se profilent fermeture des
services d'urgence fermeture de
maternité fermeture des services de
chirurgie fragilisation de la
réduitation médicale et des Samus tout
cela par marque de médecins cette
décision dont je comprends il partage la
finalité va créer dans les territoires
une situation extrêmement difficile qui
va accroître un peu plus encore
l'inégalité des Français face à l'accès
aux soins conscient des difficultés qui
s'annoncent et qui inquiète désormais de
très nombreux élus locaux vous avez
demandé aux ARS d'animer des
concertations locales territoire par
territoire avec les préfets et les élus
pour affiner les diagnostics
établissements par établissement vous
avez souhaité que les ARS construisent
des solutions avec les professionnels de
santé du territoire mais également avec
les centres hospitaliers universitaires
et des établissements sièges de
groupement de territoires vous avez
enfin rappelé que les établissements
privés s'étaient engagés à suivre le
gouvernement sur la voie d'une
rémunération raisonnée est suffisant si
cela ne l'est pas envisagez-vous
détendre cette régulation pensez-vous
madame la ministre que vos instructions
suffiront à répondre à la pénurie qui se
profile pouvez-vous nous en dire plus
sur le résultat du travail que vous avez
confié aux ARS car il y a désormais
urgences le Ségur de la santé faute de
s'être atelier une réforme en profondeur
d'une autre système de santé le rend
définitive rien réglé à une situation de
plus en plus difficile quelle est Madame
la Ministre votre plan d'action pour
assurer la permanence des soins pour
redonner confiance au système public et
libéral de santé pour que le statut des
praticiens hospitaliers salariés à
l'hôpital soit attractif et que la
question de l'intérim ne se pose plus